c'est le premier soir que nous sommes
télé diffusé des images historiques
désormais tous les canadiens peuvent
voir les débats des sénateurs en temps
réel c'est ironiquement une crise celle
du scandale des dépenses au sénat en
2013 qui a permis aux caméras d'entrer
dans la chambre haute
si vous vous rappelez dans le cadre du
débat dans la classe du sénat il avait
beaucoup de demandes de médias pour
avoir des caméras à l'intérieur pour
diffuser avec l'image parce
qu'évidemment l'image transport beaucoup
plus que seulement la voix mais il aura
fallu attendre le déménagement dans le
nouvel édifice du sénat pour que des
caméras il soit installé objectif
dépoussiérer l'institution et la rendre
plus transparents avant aujourd'hui les
caméras de télévision devait s'arrêter
ici à l'extérieur des portes de la
chambre haute
sauf pour quelques rares occasions ceux
qui s'intéressaient aux débats des
sénateurs devaient écouter la bande
sonore bien peu pour attirer l'attention
des canadiens sur leur travail
les citoyens vont par eux-mêmes se faire
une idée de ce qu'ils se nomment la
télédiffusion des débats coïncide avec
un moment où les sénateurs ont beaucoup
de pain sur la planche
ils ont entre leurs mains plusieurs
projets de loi qui concrétise des
promesses de la plateforme libérale de
2015 sans qu on ait les cotes des
téléromans les plus populaires je pense
que des projets de lois sensible qui
intéresse la population notamment le
projet de loi d'évaluation d'impacts
environnementaux qui s'en vient au sénat
va faire en sorte que les citoyens vont
prêter attention les débats en direct
n'obtiendront pas de cotes des coûts de
fracassantes mais ils seront utiles aux
journalistes qu'ils pourront reprendre
des extraits dans leurs reportages on
voit est obligé de rendre les débats un
peu plus dynamique qui ne sont
actuellement en modifiant les règlements
sinon les gens vont trouver ça ennuyeux
ponsero programme l'arrivée des caméras
dans la chambre des communes en 1977
avait aussi forcer les élus à s'ajuster
le sénateur dennis dawson était député à
l'époque j'ai vécu l'arrivée des caméras
dans l'autre choc car j'étais député et
ça a changé beaucoup les choses mais les
gens ont appris à être plus discipliné
dans le dans les interventions chaque
sénateur porte désormais une partie de
la responsabilité
sabilité de redorer le blason de
l'institution à la fin de l'exercice
chaque sénateur obligés de travailler
fort et être transparents et être prête
à défendre tout ce qu'il dit et tout ce
qui fait quand jean rené dufort la fête
quelques clips qui gêne les dessinateurs
les sénateurs vont apprendre est un peu
plus discuter ici fanny olivier radio
canada ottawa